now how's your boyfriend
right i'm going
come on
that woke you up didn't it
so what do you love most about duck the
dipping sauce the dipping sauce i love
that let's get the duck in the
set a bit of salt in there please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why do you think we put that in there
to season it and flavor it
how come do you put them in hole like
that not smaller it's going inside i'm
not using it for sauce or anything so
it's just going to make it really nice
what are they
star anise sorry
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume aroma inside
tuck that in there to get it spicy rub
all that chinese fire spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
so make sure you get it all in even the
little wings you know underneath there
just like i used to do to you in the
bath
i used to wash your little handys
i know those days are long gone i know i
know i know i should die
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there yeah so we can put it on this
little bench
okay
and that
goes
there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside all
that fat is gonna render inside the
breast so therefore it's gonna get all
nice and juicy yeah
right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part i think it really adds to the dark
it makes it really tasty cena's is your
favorite you can make it i'm gonna do
nothing okay daddy's gonna put his feet
up so uh first off the garlic
there's one good girl watch your fingers
please always do good
nice
oh you're fast
huh watch your fingers i am
watch your fingers slide slow down
please
14.
all right that's enough right a little
teaspoon of olive oil
in a few years time i'll be teaching you
how to drive
as well as cook how exciting is that
unite in a car
scary
okay garlic in
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch of black beans
nice
megan and i add soy sauce
and lastly for that classic chinese
sweet and sour element brown rice
vinegar and honey
[Music]
are you happy with the flavour i'm
really happy
you can taste everything in there
dipping sauce done ducks in the oven
let's start the dessert
the most amazing tata tan are those pink
peppercorns they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything like black peppercorns quite
sweet aren't they they're really sweet
very fruity the pink peppercorns give it
the sweetness the black peppercorns give
the heat
now
what is that baby
vanilla
this is one of the easiest desserts in
the world to make but one of the most
delicious it's a sort of take on the
classic
apple or pear to tan but when you
caramelize those bananas with the
peppercorns
and the vanilla i bet that tastes
amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay i'm gonna make the caramel start
off with the coal pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because i
want the butter to stay cold because i'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel
and caramelize the bananas at the same
time
so in goes those
vanilla vanilla seeds pods in there as
well
okay peppercorns done yeah well done
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally
nice and then look just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size wedge it into the
butter
well do you know what want the bananas
really caramelised
you just [ __ ] them between
if you crown them in like this okay it
will stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay so all
wedged in there
spreading the peppercorns on top of the
bananas so you've got that flavor
in the caramel and on the top and the
bottom
right
puff pastry
puff pastry is difficult and
time-consuming to make so i always buy
ready-made when i'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all-butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
this is where it gets really exciting
you get your fingers you just pinch the
end so you thin the end if you do that
for me very carefully you have to be
quick because the heat of your fingers
can melt the pastry how comes you do it
because we get it nice and thin so we
can clip it underneath
now take a spoon and what we do is lift
up that banana and tuck it underneath
let's see lift up a little parcel like a
parcel and see the thin bits of pastry
yeah how easy it is to get it underneath
yeah and that's why you thin them out
you do it so quickly well because i have
to be quick otherwise the pastry will
melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry that's right
see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on
we'll start caramelizing that
those three little holes are so
important
if we didn't put a hole in the pastry
and it will cause a lot of steam so the
pastry never cooks it just goes really
soggy okay so really important the
caramel is live now we're working the
camel give a little shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts oh yeah see
all comes running down
see yeah i see
now that pastry okay it's like clinging
on to the bananas and so when we turn it
upside down we've got this glove full of
these caramelised bananas
look at that
wow
it looks like look a locky
a locky ah look at likey
got you now baby
you're sorry
i'm sorry
it's your birthday soon 15.
i just worked out
i'm my 50th
you're 18.
perfect we should do a joint party yeah
i love it 12 2 4 for the old ones 12
lunchtime time till four for the old one
so they can go to sleep megan will go on
later come on perfect
here's why i get excited now look at the
color of that caramel
so tilt the pan again see how dark it is
now yeah wow it's gone a lot darker now
it didn't take long didn't take long at
all that's nearly ready for the oven but
before i put that in i'll get the duck
out wow
how's the duck doing
crispy
wow
and delicious
how crispy that is it's really crispy
that's what happens when it slow cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven 190 to 200
degrees for our banana tartar tan
time to knock up a quick hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that zingy asian punch
some freshly grated root ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy hoisin dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens
wow look at that
so
see now where that pastry is
caramelising caramel so dark and just
a little tip
gas back on
and that will release it
because if you tip it and it's still
sticking
then some of your bananas
will stick yeah so now see when it
starts spinning around like that moving
around
and here we are the moment of truth
when you know your daddy
is the best chef in the world
ready
yep
wow
the vanilla
how delicious
is really good as well
right start to stand out done crispy
dipping sauce
cucumber salad ready so if you take them
and your dipping sauce take them over
thank you i'll take the duck
don't drop it promise oh
okay
yeah
it was amazing
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes with a
hoisin dress salad and some extra oomph
from megan's favorite black bean dipping
sauce
caramelised figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green fix because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious
lay your figs out in rows take some
rosemary and just peel
that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors
trim the edge
almost we've got a
bit of a sort of sharp point bring your
three figs together
and just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stalk will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of basil
with vinegar leave them to sit there for
five minutes this sort of marinade i
know it sounds odd to use vinegar in
your dessert but trust me it gives the
dish a fantastic sweet and sour taste
i'm gonna make a really nice caramel
four or five tablespoons of sugar now
flatten that out and get it nice and
even
when the sugar is even caramel cooks
evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in
the one thing you don't do
is shake the pan rapidly
and see it almost like sort of
a lake defrosting and it's hitting to
the center
bubbling still not dark enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas knob of butter in
there
just gently
whisk in
the butter it's cooling the caramel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe lay
next add a log of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful
got that nice
dark
richness of the caramel a little touch
of water in there
that way the caramel doesn't go too
thick
now put the caramel back on the heat
take your figs and sort of place them in
gently
lovely
and then just add all that lovely little
marinade
[Music]
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar embossed on the vinegar
there's something so tasty
baste
those figs
because the
skin
gets nice and crispy on the outside
and the fig sort of just absorbs the
caramel
delicious
so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
the
smell is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that caramel
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese
the freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
i'm gonna finish that now
with some
zest
and then
some little nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy jam texture of the
fig
with the ricotta
is brilliant that is an amazing way of
slow roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
pan on for the stuffing
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of rolls-royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing to an absolute tea for
the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt and pepper make sure the stuffing
is beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamb
now we've got the color on those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts
and that helps to give a bit of a
texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in
and just lay the spinach over the pine
nuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
going to condense and disappear almost
instantly
there's so much more flavor in spinach
when you saute it as opposed to steaming
it or boiling it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumpled feta over the spinach
feta cheese adds a beautifully salty
sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings our stuffing together
now
open up
the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
soulmate sumac is a wonderful lemony
spice that goes brilliantly with lamb
and you can get it in most big
supermarkets and it sort of cuts through
that
thick rich sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon
if you're preparing this for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's gonna
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of
increase that beautiful tunnel
and then from there
over
there
and bring that
towards you
and then roll
like i said some of the stuff is going
to come out
now
just tie it first off
around the side
and don't worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops i got
two ties
go to tight it just forces all that
stuffing out of the lamb when it's in
the oven
nice
now we'll just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it very nicely coloured
none of your stuffing is coming out the
sides really important
look at that color beautiful does kick
start the roasting process
gas off
into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tail the cucumber
peel it
cut the cucumber
into three
and just core
taking out all that it's just sort of
watery seedy and
it spoils the flavor slice cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
gonna dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt a couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint
dressing a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb is rested
carefully take off the string
and then just gently pull them back
a serrated edge knife that's going to
cut through that crispy fat on the
outside instantly
i tied it purposely so i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay
and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing meats
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast so if you want wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in little bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so what kind of cream is that in there
dad that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich
chocolate mousse what's your favorite
sort of chocolate is it white milk dark
um i love white and milk
what's yours i absolutely love milk
chocolate oh that's my guilty pleasure
is it really here we go cream in
so that goes in there
now
you can see what's happening straight
away can't you it's melting really
quickly melting really quickly so okay
oh excuse me
at least your jumper's white so you
won't spot it yeah i've got a nice
little snack for later
in another bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks
the lime cuts the sort of richness of
the cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
mmm it smells really good the lime gives
it a really nice zingyness xenos you're
absolutely right
next add to the melted chocolate mixture
because i'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have a little taste
nice yeah the lime gives it a really
nice taste telly i need the rest for the
mousse
i need them for my tummy no come on
chocolate moves into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites
this is where i need you at your
absolute best okay because to whip those
whites it's gonna be really tough so
we'll take it in turns 30 seconds each
okay you go first
10 seconds gone
come on tilly 15 seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
exit hold the ball
right
no
no way
[Music]
30 seconds this puny little thing and
you come with a big little machine gun
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
start tipping that sugar in
slowly don't look very happy in there
our contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cool white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets
the egg whites keep the cream nice and
fluffy and you get this nice light
mousse in the bowl now i need you to
crush some raspberries please with some
fresh
you can see all mint juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow
that looks really cool now look at that
down the bottom there little
crushed raspberry delicious
now i'm going to set that in the fridge
if you miss a count over the door please
our yummy white chocolate mousse will
take at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our mediterranean-inspired
vegetarian starter
griddle courgette ricotta and mint
bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grilled look
cut thick slices of chapatta bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimetre thick
pieces
drizzle and coat in olive oil and season
with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the cagets are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty topata with dollops
of minty ricotta and top with your
seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
no i haven't actually shallots please
into the pan for daddy
add a sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important
to have your stock
gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock
yeah because you can't have different
stocks if it's more vegetarian can you
i made that mistake once putting beef
stock in the vegetarian soup
no i didn't matilda are you sure i'm
positive i'm joking
fry off time how nice does that smell it
smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice this is elboria rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stocking without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for daddy
it's just gonna make a fun day no flambe
on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
i'm adding red wine
followed by the first ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off wow
it's giving it a cloudy sort of look
what's happening to the stock the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
whenever risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking there we
have to kill it all the way okay ready
for the next ladle i'm ready good girl
here we go ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
beetroots
peel them rub them a little bit of salt
and sugar yeah and a little bit of aged
balsamic vinegar in there roasted them
i'm a great my parmesan
how's that rice doing the rice is doing
good
now that is exactly where we want to be
now look look at that nice glossy
textured rice
so beetroot i want you to put two thirds
of the beetroot in there for me saving
one-third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
nice it's like it's snowing again and
then we're just gonna get some nice
butter in there
the butter gives the risotto a really
nice gloss
look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spoon in there now
for daddy
beautifully there you go good
wonderful
shake it risotto should be like lava
it just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
and then
finish
some extra virgin olive oil
on top
there
i'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
let's go daddy
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and thyme
risotto
and for put an indulgent white chocolate
and lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries
you